well what has taught me I said we but
with a good luck chop after last year's
like a calls boom what more do you want
thought Melia done the weight of award
show of their last cust yeah what do I
see if I win the award Lawrence thanks
good night I'm gonna probably see a bit
more than that Lawrence okay Brian
[Music]
because they're not even get your name
on the [__] same lame [__] house
I've just seen Haley McQueen and she
looked [__] beautiful she looked
itaúnas you know did you see that oh
that's that concert is talking about me
all spent on the podcast
the guy from visual prestige may you've
done bits I've got to give it up there
are you confident about winning the
award Lud that's why I came dressed as a
teacher on parents evening I'm not
confident of winning
I've just seen Haley between it oh I'm
aware of this she told me about that
nine times 20 times Brian what you
noticed was when she went she just being
beaten under ward by Standard Life
Investments we got 11,000 views for a
month ago summit
so you've got to give them credit 11,000
views [__] done I'll do that concurrent
you [__] prick I'll do that life I
[__] Chrissie buns just rocked up he's
wearing the exact same thing he was when
I [__] to the podcast with him any
chance woody he's such a [__]
[Music]
we shall finish it let him talk heylia
McQueen tonight
you bought ice cream how many more
dreams can come true
everything's just gonna coordinate blood
everything's coming up Bryan house so
into award show the night full of [__]
big waves and mainstream media I looked
at who I was up against if you've got a
numbers and actually interaction of you
lot I'm winning no problem it's fair to
say when we lost the award I probably
didn't take it very well but I got a
selfie with the number one Sky Sports
girl who was the real winner me and I'm
really drunk so I've gotta get up in the
morning because I've got to go a Paris
with Lawrence cuz I'm gonna make a video
yeah in 15 minutes trains coming
typical clown brings all these cameras
[__] everything up and now I'm here in
Lawrence corn even find as possible I
literally can't believe I'm here I'm not
this isn't even for a blog I'm being
serious I didn't even want to come the
fronts I literally did I did this as a
favor Lawrence and now he's not even
here and I'm on a [__] tree run
little bit of Paris everything's just
going wrong Lawrence has managed to
fight these plus support he's coming but
he's not gonna be here for a while all
that boring [__] that he had planned Oh
laughter design New York souvenirs
he's been asking for one so and I didn't
get him in for Christmas bodybuilding
for your penis
I'm in France in about a loose piece of
Google T's destination this is such a
beautiful view I could crack I wonder if
you get inside them arise so yeah it's
been a great day did I tell you about me
hotel room oh now that is a tree this is
the front door this is my hotel I live
now when I was offshore me story I'll
tell a lie there's a there's a toilet is
the sink up there is the shower that
seems small here it's because it [__]
is me the good thing is I'll be so
[__] blind when I get back I don't
mean to say it if it's the Sun you can
see how far is good job he's got a
little dick as Neil eyes are really
[__] over
that's just what curse he told us me
ignore ah I'm sure it's perfectly fine
I'm lovely little romantic meal here few
years ago I used to work on boats things
have changed it's all people who've
helped me and everyone in town Cheers
sometimes I think that myself you know
have experiences like this maybe I
should go back died why we come right
it's a stupid idea money on them ah
where every just arrived you see though
knew that's where all the models on I've
just been through all of that just all
really hide me and it slices I'm not
sure that for me if you honest I'll I'll
prefer women with low expectations not
once you want to be taken to this sort
of event you know that not all of them
have been taken somewhere there Brian a
lot of these women are here of their own
independent militia they they've all
worked hard to get here use need to be
taken away from the hard work made
bumblebee on the back of wills t-shirt
size of a [__] shoebox means the
shower do you know when you see G
respond scaling alongside a building
before he gets into a window that's how
I had to get into the shower so that was
interesting so I'm supposed to be in
amongst all this Rasta [__] partly
we're supposed to be interviewing people
but what do you say of them you know how
fast you go idea car I'm just going to
sit here and let Lawrence handle Lola
learn and Kay tried to resurrect his
career their blessing done a little bit
of complain and I'm not gonna lie use of
intolerance now that we've gone through
all of that struggle got the phone
graph across like that it's all being
worth it
thank you thanks Lawrence yeah I'm
really really really happy lad now we're
on my way back
all it was is our first domino the Gila
McQueen and now it's they're all
dropping like flies my gender is me yeah
like one big sexual jingchou Jordy
[Music]
where I'm standing right now this was
the spot on my first ever New Castle
much Alan Shearer stood for he killed a
free-kick right into that top corner
they but I'm about to play a football
match here William what he omit my
Lynette what position you play the D
Lawrence I'm strike I'll be buggin the
goals I'm not gonna keep running if
people are gonna [__] pushes when I'm
a normal girl might as well just [__]
off entirely still raging
Howdy's player his chance and James is
still raging
well Brian come on Rob Brydon he had was
sayin curly and the heart just said
smush the [__] and I'll live with that
decision but let's say I die
I've lived out me boy your dream all
thanks to you a lot so I'll be coming
are you pretty
what's your motivation for idea when you
get a hard title what you're gonna think
about charity man charity soldiers fan
it's all fun there's nothing fun about
this this is do or die bed-stuy
I reckon willing he's gonna smash your
[__] really that's it you can even
like weight-wise that much I'm gonna be
commandeered yeah I just got it
straightened this is like 30 million
museum I've got to be in here somewhere
sorry off you carry on what you were
saying about support and Tommy Robinson
to be fair he said sympathetic you
didn't say supportive as soon as the
camera goes on the real Alfie disappears
luckily got the back of footage right
here so mr. Lawrence this is for you
[Applause]
there's a reason we're keeping up there
and now it's time for another episode of
Brian's people someone just called me
beautiful they get that
come here fortunes in this club it's
[__] great this is the self Oh God he
was pretty decent as you can see
thinking wait man it'll be ready when
I'm ready for back two out of three
ain't bad
that's what they always say to us tobe
Jizzle sported a Mario Balotelli like a
cook he did that after the sidemen hit
15,000 he shaved the movi and 20,000 he
colored it and we are on that way well
done told me just what can they take
it's gonna be exciting this get worse
his right lungs there JJ with a good
Tuttle to start the game off and if
Logan port watching he's got more other
for you me will any is absolutely
furious that they let him tackle well
what has taught me I said we were with a
good luck job after last year's like a
calls boom what more do you want
thought Melia well that's it another
commentary job done the unsung hero
strikes again holding it together
everything falling apart
keep your head that's what I do
subscribe I see is there